[Music]
dylan
you son of a [ __ ]
the matter
the ca got you pushing too many pencils
we all love a good action movie but when
you're considering thousands of action
movies it's only the most thrilling the
most exciting the most brutal and the
influential who make the cut
get away from her
action is a wide open genre and term and
we endeavor to include something from
every style every era and movement of
action movies these are the action
movies whose influence can still be seen
in the films that followed they spawned
franchises pushed back against time
defined and even expanded the genre do
you really think you have a chance
against us mr cowboy
these are the badass movies that make
audiences feel cooler from having seen
them so let's count down the best action
movies all ranked by tomato meter
[Music]
starting with number 10 terminator 2
judgment day
young john connor the key to
civilization's victory over a future
robot uprising is the target of the
shape-shifting t-1000 a terminator sent
from the future to kill him another
terminator the revamp t800 has been sent
back to protect the boy as john and his
mother go on the run with the t-800 the
boy forms an unexpected bond with the
robot starring arnold schwarzenegger
linda hamilton edward furlong and
directed by james cameron critics say t2
features thrilling action sequences and
eye-popping visual effects but what
takes this sci-fi action landmark to the
next level is the depth of the human and
cyborg characters
don't stop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
number nine speed
la police officer jack angers retired
bomb squad member howard payne by
foiling his attempt at taking hostages
in revenge payne arms a bus with a bomb
that will explode if it drops below 50
miles per hour with the help of spunky
passenger annie jack and his partner
harry try to save the bus and the people
aboard before the bomb goes off all
while also trying to figure out how
payne is monitoring them starring keanu
reeves dennis hopper sandra bullock and
directed by john de bonne critics say a
terrific popcorn thriller speed is tot
tense and energetic with outstanding
performances from keanu reeves dennis
hopper and sandra bullock sir
i need to take your phone take the phone
drugstore
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[ __ ]
number eight die hard
new york city policeman john mclean is
visiting his estranged wife and two
daughters on christmas eve he joins her
at a holiday party in the headquarters
of the japanese-owned business that she
works for but the festivities are
interrupted by a group of terrorists who
take over the exclusive high-rise and
everyone in it very soon mclean realizes
that there's no one to save the hostages
but him starring bruce willis alan
rickman reginald veljohnson and directed
by john mctiernan critics say die hard's
many imitators and sequels have never
come close to matching the top thrills
of the definitive holiday action classic
architecture
so
[Music]
she's
[Music]
shoot the glass
number seven enter the dragon
bruce lee plays a martial arts expert
determined to help capture the narcotics
dealer whose gang was responsible for
the death of his sister lee enters a
kung fu competition in an attempt to
fight his way to the dealer's
headquarters with the help of some
friends starring bruce lee john saxon
anna capri and directed by robert klaus
critics say bad ass to the max enter the
dragon is the ultimate kung fu movie and
fitting if untimely bruce lee swan song
oh
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
number six raiders of the lost ark
dr indiana jones a renowned
archaeologist and expert in the occult
is hired by the united states government
to find the ark of the covenant and the
ten commandments within unfortunately
hitler's agents are also after the ark
and india and his ex-flame marion escape
from various closed scrapes in a quest
that takes him from nepal to cairo
starring harrison ford karen allen paul
freeman and directed by steven spielberg
critics say featuring bervira set pieces
sly humor and white knuckle action
raiders of the lost ark is one of the
most consummately entertaining adventure
pictures of all time
uh
[Music]
number five black panther
after the death of his father t'challa
returns home to the african nation of
wakanda to take his rightful place as
king when a powerful enemy suddenly
reappears t'challa's medal is king and
as black panther gets tested when he's
drawn into a conflict that puts the fate
of wakanda and the entire world at risk
faced with treachery and danger the
young king must rally his allies and
release the power of black panther to
defeat his foes and secure the safety of
his people starring chadwick boseman
michael b jordan lupita nyong'o and
directed by ryan coogler critics say
black panther elevates superhero cinema
to thrilling new heights while telling
one of the mcu's most absorbing stories
and introducing some of its most fully
realized characters protect the other
two i see a shortcut
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm not going to make
it keep going
hey what was that don't worry about it
you're doing great
number four crouching tiger hidden
dragon
in 19th century shang dynasty china a
warrior gives his sword green destiny to
his lover to deliver to safe keeping but
when it's stolen the chase is on to find
it the search leads to the house of you
where the story takes on an entirely
different level starring chao yoon fat
michelle yeo shung xi yi and directed by
ang lee critics say the movie that
catapulted angli into the ranks of upper
echelon hollywood filmmakers crouching
tiger hidden dragon features a deft mix
of amazing martial arts battles
beautiful scenery and tasteful drama
[Music]
[Music]
ally
[ __ ]
[Music]
number three mission impossible fallout
ethan hunt and the imf team joined
forces with cia assassin august walker
to prevent a disaster of epic
proportions arms dealer john lark and a
group of terrorists known as the
apostles plan to use three plutonium
cores for a nuclear attack on the
vatican jerusalem and mecca saudi arabia
when the weapons go missing ethan and
his crew find themselves in a desperate
race against time to prevent them from
falling into the wrong hands starring
tom cruise henry cavill wing rhames and
directed by christopher macquarie
critics say fast leak and fun mission
impossible fallout lives up to the
impossible part of its name by setting
yet another high mark for insane set
pieces in a franchise full of them
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
number two aliens
after floating in space for 57 years
lieutenant ripley shuttle is found by a
deep space salvage team upon arriving at
lv 426 the marines find only one
survivor a nine-year-old girl named newt
but even these battle-hardened marines
with all the latest weaponry are no
match for the hundreds of aliens that
have invaded the colony starring
sigourney weaver michael bean bill
paxton and directed by james cameron
critics say while alien was a marvel of
slow building atmospheric tension aliens
packs a much more visceral punch and
features a typically strong performance
from sigourney weaver
maybe they don't show up on infrared at
all
come on
jesus christ what is going on
down
sound off
frost
[Music]
let's rock
who's firing damn it
i ordered the whole fire
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the matrix
neo believes that morpheus an elusive
figure considered to be the most
dangerous man alive can answer his
question what is the matrix neo is
contacted by trinity a beautiful
stranger who leads him into an
underworld where he meets morpheus they
fight a brutal battle for their lives
against a cadre of viciously intelligent
secret agents and it is a truth that
could cause neo something more precious
than his life starring keanu reeves
lawrence fishburne carrianne moss and
directed by the wachowskis critics say
thanks to the wachowski's imaginative
vision the matrix is a smartly crafted
combination of spectacular action and
groundbreaking special effects
[Music]
what is he doing
he's beginning to believe
you're empty
so are you
[Music]
uh
heat master criminal neil mccauley is
trying to control the rogue actions of
one of his men while also planning one
last big heist before retiring meanwhile
lieutenant hannah attempts to track down
mccauley as he deals with the chaos in
his own life including the infidelity of
his wife and the mental health of his
stepdaughter macaulay and hannah
discover a mutual respect even as they
try to thwart each other's plans
starring al pacino robert de niro val
kilmer and directed by michael mann
critics say though al pacino and robert
de niro share but a handful of screen
minutes together heat is an engrossing
crime drama that draws compelling
performances from its stars and confirms
michael mann's mastery of the genre
so
predator
dutch a soldier of fortune is hired by
the united states government to secretly
rescue a group of politicians trapped in
guatemala but when dutch and his team
which includes weapons expert blaine and
cia agent george land in central america
something is gravely wrong after finding
a string of dead bones the crew
discovers that they're being hunted by a
brutal creature with superhuman strength
and the ability to disappear into its
surroundings starring arnold
schwarzenegger carl weathers jesse
ventura and directed by john mctiernan
critics say predator part sci-fi part
horror part action all muscle
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
and finally number one mad max fury road
years after the collapse of civilization
the tyrannical immortan joe enslaves
apocalypse survivors inside the desert
fortress the citadel when the warrior
imperator furiosa leads the
five wives in a daring escape she forges
an alliance with max rockatansky a loner
and former captive fortified in the
massive armored truck the war rig they
try to outrun the ruthless warlord and
his henchmen in a deadly high-speed
chase through the wasteland starring tom
hardy charlize theron nicholas holt and
directed by george miller critics say
with exhilarating action and a
surprising amount of narrative heft mad
max fury road brings george miller's
post-apocalyptic franchise roaring
vigorously back to life
buddy
get up
you can do it
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of that
entertainment content you love until
next time i am your host naz perez and
we will see you back here for more top
10s on the rotten tomatoes countdown
you